Thank you, so what I am going to talk about
here today is how to build a WYSIWYM editor
in the browser.
By what you see is what you mean, we usually
mean something like what you see is what you
get, WYSIWYG where you have a visual representation
of you content and can just edit that in the
obvious classical way, but instead of editing
things like
font size margins you are editing semantic
information so you get reduced cleaner representation
of the document where you say this is a paragraph,
this is a link, and not this is Georgia 15
pixels italic.
This is usually beneficial when you want to
have users edit content and you then later
want to use it in a different layout in a
different context or you want to inspect it,
and transform it somehow, it's very useful
to have semantic information about the content
rather than just layout information.
So, my newest project is called ProseMirror
I am going to be talking about CodeMirror
and ProseMirror you shouldn't confuse them,
ProseMirror is a semantic rich text editor,
so something like a WYSIWYG but for clean
content.
This was recently launched and open sourced
and it's my attempt to build an editor where
you can define a schema for you content and
have the editor automatically enforce that
and provide the user with editing actions
that stay within your schema so if you have
for example your Github you have you document
model that includes references to issues and
commits you can't extend your document model
to have first clause now it's links to commits
or links to users or whatever and have your
users actually be working with a data model
that corresponds to what you actually want
to work with.
ProseMirror also supports collaborative editing
and is generally I hope the future of in-browser
prose writing.
So yeah I am going to be talking about how
it's implemented and a major factor in any
kind of rich text editing implementation is
the browser API called contentEditable.
This is what enables many browser almost all
in-browser WYSIWYGs to exist at all if you
talk to people who have worked with it you
will get complaints and lots of horrible stories.
So let me give a bit of background history.
So the year is 1979, Microsoft is on a roll
when it comes to browser they just ported
JavaScript, introduced dynamic DOM manipulation
then I guess I don't really know what happened
but assume someone there said let's make our
browser and editor so people can write HTML
in the browser it's a very commendable idea.
What they ended up doing in IE 4 is introducing
a feature called designMode a property you
set on your document which makes the whole
document editable what it means is still not
completely clear there's no spec that covers
this you can type into it you can back space
out stuff and a companion to this API is document.exec
command which your scripts can call string
like bold or italic or insert ordered list
or delete to perform other editing actions
on the document.
What you could do since IE 4 is create a frame,
set to it be editable and then bind some key
binding and buttons some various exec command
codes you would have a basic WYSIWYG editor.
This has worked since 1997, then in 2000 they
added a second feature very simple to that
called contentEditable this is the same as
designMode but per DOM node instead of the
whole document.
You don't have to create an iFrame you can
just in your existing content set the switch
to make it editable to let your users add
something to a piece of your page then save
it somehow.
Other
important thing you could do since this feature
was introduced was set pieces of an editable
DOM node to be non editable you could set
it back to false to be inside of the node,
that means that well the users can edit text
round it but they can't move their cursor
into that node and start editing there.
This is also a big improvement, it allows
you to protect some part of your document
or insert widgets that are not necessarily
editable.
So, this was pretty much before the big JavaScript
boom but people were slowly starting to use
this at some point it become really wide spread,
I think CK editors from the early 2000s not
sure when tiny MC started they were libraries
reping this and people using content management
systems.
At Mozilla there was a feeling we have to
do something like this, it's a useful feature,
but they didn't quite like what Microsoft
had done, and this was the browser war so
it was not like there was a very good communication
of standards process.
They spent sometime trying to come up with
a better solution but they never really agreed
on something.
So in the end they said ok we'll just do what
Internet Explorer does so we're no longer
left out when it comes to rich text editor
in-browser.
So they copied this feature, of course it
didn't exactly copy it they some parts of
it were no use they left those out, they thought
they knew better solutions for some other
parts for example where IE would add text
if you made something bold, they said no we
have CSS that font width on them.
IE had the feature on both major browsers
then and a few years later, actually took
until 2007 which is past the JavaScript boom
that Firefox also added support for contentEditable,
and then the other browsers Safari, Chrome,
Opera, all also took up the feature and implemented
it one way or another and now it's kind of
considered part of the expected API in a modern
graphical browser.
So why is this a good thing?
The other controls that we have to implement
editing in a browser are text area and text
input.
Both of which are constrained to atomic blobs
of plain text you can't really do many of
the things you want to do with them like doing
rich text in them is a non starter and even
adding some helpful widgets or syntax highlighting
is almost impossible to do on top of text
area.
So it's great then we have an alternative
that we can do solid rich text editing or
more or less solid rich text editing in a
browser, things like content management systems
that exist entirely online, earlier code editors
were also based on this.
This is wonderful.
Except of course, it has problems a major
thing HTML scope is not gigantic, you might
not want that whole scope for example, first
version of CodeMirror it was based on contentEditable
images links whole tables into the editor
I had to somehow deal with this.
So you can do that you can filter content,
you properly want to filter the content anyway,
it comes out of this by default, it's very,
very ugly.
So that modern WYSIWYG browsers have pretty
advanced mechanisms for cleaning out the HTML
inside of the editor, but then there's still
all the browser differences, there's no spec,
each browser.
This is a very big scope of what editing HTML
really means, there's cursor motion through
tables, adding columns to table, what happens
when you present enter in a definition list,
what exactly is the cursor position if it's
moving across the boundaries of block elements,
what is a valid cursor position.
These are all valid questions, they came up
with slightly different answers to them.
Then there's bugs.
Many
bugs.
The feeling I get is that no-one really maybe
except for the few engineers that started
this thing, no-one really felt like implementing
this but it was something that is needed and
expected and so all the browser vendors had
to somehow ad this dragon of a sub browser
that interacted with everything in all kinds
of horrible ways, bugs with language and bug
trackers for years an years it seems no-one
really cared all that much.
The situation has recently improved, currently
on modern browsers you can really make some
assumptions about what is going to happen
to your HTML as the user is editing it, didn't
used to be the case in CodeMirror 1, I have
just piles and piles of workarounds to deal
with all these weird issues.
It was only a text editor, it will be a lot
worse if you actually support rich content.
So, people really got annoyed with this and
then there is a generation of editors, it
started with code editors, who just say, "Ok,
we're not going to touch this at all, we'll
figure something out ourselves, we implement
everything, so we implement our own selection,
just the DOM is not actually editable, we
pretend it is by capturing events and changing
your documents you see on the screen in response
to these events."
The first one to pull this off was the Ace
code editor at that point I was still messing
about with contentEditable in my own code
editing, I thought ok this is clearly superior,
I just dropped content editor and never went
back.
Google docs, uses this, what you see blinking
on the green is a little gif that's hidden
and shown periodically, you can very far,
on desk top browsers you can get a good editing
experience using this technique.
At some point you do run into problems, if
you maintain your own selection entirely,
you get all the complexity of bi directional
text on your plate you have to implement what
the cursor is supposed to be doing, if it
moves right to left, then enters left to right
text and there is an island of... if you are
mixing Arabic or Hebrew or other scripts you
get islands inside of your paragraphs that
are running in different directions, people
need like this.
Like Arabic or Hebrew writers really need
this to be work, you can't do much with your
editor if it doesn't work, it's gigantically
difficult to get it right.
The content menu should shows cut and paste,
if you click on it, if you have a non-editable
gif there, it won't know.
You can find the hex for this, the hex for
this is to pop-up a tiny transparent text
area under the cursor when the user right
clicks and hooks up the right thing when he
cuts or pastes, you can get it to work but
it's painful or awkward.
Then, mobile interfaces, touch interfaces
became widespread and the integration Between
the selection and touch interface is very
deep and very subtle, producing a native selection,
a native field to manipulate the selection
when you are not actually letting the browser
know about the selection is almost impossible,
I don't think anyone has pulled it off yet.
So this may not be the right solution either.
So maybe let's meet in the middle and this
is the idea that prompted ProseMirror, give
the editor the visible DOM, when the user
does something and it generates an event,
we step in and say doing do anything browser,
we'll handle this and get - isolate this from
a lot of the horrors of contentEditable, the
random manipulation by the DOM is no longer
happens, it allows us to define the model
and be the
only one touching that, in the older approach
the DOM is your document model.
You don't keep your own copy of the data you
let the DOM determine what the document looks
like, you don't know what the browser will
do with this, it's like building on quicksand,
things might change, notes that you somehow
depending on existing might be replaced by
a copy, having full control offer your document
model is a very useful thing to do and I think
some of the other WYSIWYGs that have cropped
up recently are also moving in this direction.
.
Yeah, ProseMirror is designed from the ground
up with the assumption that we have a document
model and then there is a DOM, the DOM is
a view on the document model, the document
is solid we have it entirely, when it's changed
we update the DOM ourselves and show the user
the pseudo editable thing, it's supposed to
be editable but we don't let them edict directly,
the selection is not a real selection you
can manipulate on a touch interface, bi directional
cursor motion by bi directional text can be
left through the browser, we dent want to
think about that, that saves complexity.
Of course implementing our own document model
and all possible changes is also a lot of
complexity, but this is complexity I think
you want as a text editor, you want to define
it in one predictable, well-defined way.
You want to make them customisable, you want
to cut out the browser when it comes to that.
So I'm going to go into ProseMirror document
model for a bit, three base much like the
DOM, if you have a document with a list of
three items, it looks something like this.
You get a list now or three item notes, paragraph
notes with some text content in it.
One thing that it does very differently from
the DOM it's a persistent data structure,
so if you update it you create a new version
and the old version is untouched, so you just
don't go in there and start adding children,
I don't know where.
There is a well-defined set of possible updates
and you apply an update to get a new document.
This is not as expensive as it sounds, it
can do data sharing if you an item to this
list here, you just reuse the old item notes
and make a copy of the document and the list
notes, the fourth child in the list notes,
you are only copying two notes rather than
your whole document structure.
Another thing that ProseMirror does differently
from the DOM, when you have in line content
this is how you represent a paragraph with
a bees of link and note text in it, you create
a subtree with for example a strong note and
you put the content that's strong under that.
ProseMirror actually makes linear, where in
line paragraph content is always a sequence
of pieces of text with styling information
and images or notes that can appear here,
they don't nest, beyond the paragraph level
there is no nesting you can see how this is
harder to read than this.
It's the same when you are dealing with it
in code, a lot of the things you want to do
are much easier on this, for example, verifying
that you are not emphasising a piece of text
twice, it's trivial and this tree representation
is a pain in the... tree representation similarly
if we want to represent positions in the paragraph
we can just a character offset and we
don't have to worry about tree relations.
So this was a big win and made it easier to
define a lot of things.
So let's see what happens when ProseMirror
captures events.
You have your editor, it's rendered a piece
of editable DOM corresponding to the document
it has itself in memory software, and someone
presses 'A', we capture an event for that
and create a change object.
Changes in ProseMirror are first class objects
which you can store and pass around and we'll
come back to that later.
Then we apply the change object to our current
documents, get the new documents, make that
the current documents and schedule a DOM update,
similarly if you press 'Backspace', you just
compute what you want to be deleting with
backspace, create a change, take the content
of the clipboard, pass it into our document
format and replace the selection with this
document fragment to get another change object.
Updating the DOM is then done by, as I scheduling
updates using request information frames,
the next time the browser does an actual redraw
it will first run are code which is responsible
for making sure the DOM reflects the current
document the nice thing about the persistent
dock searches we can do pretty much react,
we can div the document with the current document
and make the changes only that are necessary
to the DOM to move to the new document, this
is insanely efficient and fast, we can just
do one point to compare, ok, nothing changed
here and move on to the next note.
Of course it's not entirely perfect, in some
cases parses do not fire good events, - you
write click and choose another spelling of
this world, then it will just modify the DOM
and then say, "Input", meaning something changed,
you don't know anything about it.
So, we have to deal with that and in this
case we just take the part of the DOM, like
the block elements around the cursor, reparse
those, div those with our understanding of
what those parts of that document look like
and arrive at change from that, fortunately
I've only run into this problem for simple
textual changes and deriving a simple text
change is safe, nothing weird can happen there,
so far this is working well I'm still expecting
at some point to run into more problems here.
So, having all these persistent objects representing
everything in a nice value way, we can define
a kind of algebra of changes, the basic operation
is applying the change to a document.
Here we have a blue thing for a document and
an orange thing for a change and we apply
that getting a new document, in this case
we delete the part in 0 paragraph between
character off set 2 and 8, we get a new document
object and also a map.
A map is a position map, it's a way to associate
positions in the pre-change version of the
document with positions in the post change
document, in this case we can query this map
to ask cursor position in the first paragraph
at position 11 in the old document, where
is this in the new document.
It will say, "It's positioned 05", meaning
the fifth character in the first... this is
mainly used for making the cursor move as
the document changes, so it shouldn't jump
around but stay in its position.
There is a bunch of nice things you can
do with this, like checking pieces of the
document you just create two positions in
the document around the part you are interested
in, you keep mapping those to the new document
and you end up knowing where the text you
are checking ended up, it's also essential
for collaborative editing, it allows us by
mapping the positions associated with the
change object to move changes from one document
to another version of that document.
So, for example, if we had beyond this delete
operation we had another change object saying,
"Insert a character at position 11", we can
now say that same change but applied to the
second document is, insert the same character
at position 5, so if you have a collaborative
editing set up and two users make it concurrently,
one of them will end up going first and the
other one will have this change that they
have made, but that they're not able to apply
to the current document because the document
changed in the meantime.
They can use this approach to take the change
that the other user made, move their own changeover
it and then apply it and retry pushing it
to the server, so it's kind of like, get to
base, you try to push, you get a conflict,
you try to rebase locally and then you try
to repush again, it works quite well, there
is quite a bit to it actually, you can find
a long discrimination on my blog, it works
quite well, it's a relatively simple and solid
way to do collaborative editing.
There is more applications of this, say change
tracking, if you just keep a history of all
your changes, you can always find out where
a piece of the document originated, stuff
like that.
I'm sure there is more, we haven't really
explored this far yet, but it's a nice place
to, nice basis to build on.
Then I want to, very briefly talk about the
future.
So, the W 3 C is working on an update to this
contentEditable standard which would allow
a new mode of contentEditable, where you are
supposed to do exactly this, the document
isn't editable, you are supposed to capture
events and edit the inventory yourself, then
they will also have to define a few more events
for stuff like the spell checking issue that
I showed before and a bunch more like this,
but yeah, that would be nice because it relives
the browser vendors of maintaining this whole
horrible blob of code and it gives editor
implementers a view of how to implement a
robust solid editor, without going insane
in the process.
Of course, you never know when W 3 C standard
will actually end up in browsers, but I'm
told that browsers are enthusiastic about
this, probably for the reasons I mentioned,
it will probably be happening, but the specification
isn't finished yet, it will probably be a
long time.
This is the URLs, the ProseMirror.net and
Github.com/ProseMirror.
Feel free to play with it, it's not finished
yet but it works as it is, the major big thing
that has to improve is the API or language
for defining your own document schemers and
having flexible for all the things you might
want in your document schemer.
We are having a meet up on Monday around this
project here in Berlin, if you think you might
be interested, go to discuss.ProseMirror.net,
a discussion forum and one of the topics is
this
meet up, you are welcome to apply as well.
That's it, thank you for listening.
.